It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Last fall, I saw this video from a high school in Michigan, and maybe it wouldn't have stayed with me in the way that it has if it weren't for all the many things that have happened since then that keep reminding me of this video. It's turned into a sort of reference point in my head for a dynamic I keep seeing repeated.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。去年秋天，我看到了密歇根州一所高中的视频，如果不是因为从那以后发生的许多事情不断让我想起这个视频，它可能不会像现在这样留在我的脑海中。它在我心中变成了一个参考点，让我不断看到同样的动态在重演。
The video is from September 2021, last fall, in Michigan, about 20 miles outside of Ann Arbor. It's early morning, right before the school day. A group of parents and their high schoolers are loosely crowded around the door to a school, a mostly white crowd. There's a police officer with Top Gun sunglasses.
这段视频拍摄于2021年9月，去年秋天，地点在密歇根州，安娜堡外约20英里处。那是清晨，学校一天开始之前。一群家长和他们的高中生零散地挤在校门口，人群中大多是白人。有一名戴着《壮志凌云》风格太阳镜的警察。
You're going to go in the building. You have to have a mask on.
如果要进教学楼，你们必须戴上口罩。
And what would be the repercussions if they don't have a mask?
如果不戴口罩会有什么后果？
If you don't want to go in, you don't have to.
如果你不想进去，你可以不进去。
The officer is calmly-- one might say, patronizingly-- repeating, "If you're going to go into the building, you have to have a mask on." Nobody in this video is wearing a mask. About 20 teenagers are standing between the officer and the door to their school, looking like all teenagers do when they're waiting for anything-- a little bored, a little blank, lots of crossed arms-- as this goes on.
警察平静地——或许可以说，带着屈尊俯就的态度——重复着：“如果要进教学楼，你们必须戴上口罩。”视频里没有人戴口罩。大约20名青少年站在警察和校门之间，看起来就像所有青少年在等待什么时那样——有点无聊，有点茫然，很多人双臂交叉——随着事态的持续。
I'm not going to force anybody. I'm not putting masks on anybody. That's not my job.
我不会强迫任何人。我不会给任何人戴口罩。那不是我的工作。
So they can go in without the masks?
所以他们可以不戴口罩进去吗？
This is a county health department order and a policy of the school--
这是县卫生部门的命令和学校的政策——
Right.
没错。
--that if anybody that's going to go in--
——任何要进入的人——
It's not.
并不是。
--they've got to have a mask on.
——都必须戴上口罩。
There is no policy.
根本没有这种政策。
I'm not arguing.
我不想争论。
OK. So they can go in, guys.
好吧。所以他们可以进去，孩子们。
They can go in.
他们可以进去。
They can go in. Go on in, guys.
他们可以进去。进去吧，孩子们。
Go in.
进去。
The officer has just said, no, you can't go in. And the parents start waving the kids toward the door, yelling, you can go in. Some of the teenagers look, reasonably, a little confused, like didn't the cop just say the exact opposite? But they all turn and slowly move toward the door, where the principal and superintendent are standing with masks on. And the kids are just trapped there in a big clump.
警察刚刚才说，不，你们不能进去。家长们就开始招呼孩子们走向门口，大喊着你们可以进去。有些青少年看起来理所当然地有些困惑，仿佛警察刚才说的不是完全相反的话吗？但他们全都转过身，缓慢地朝门口走去，校长和督导员正戴着口罩站在那里。孩子们就这样被困在那里，挤成一团。
You guys, they can't touch you. Just go ahead and go in.
孩子们，他们不能碰你们。直接进去吧。
I remember watching this and thinking, what is it like to be those high schoolers, stuck in between your principal and your parent, between two authorities who are each so certain they have the moral high ground when it comes to your life?
我记得看着这一幕时心想，作为那些高中生是什么感觉？被夹在校长和家长之间，夹在两个都自认为在你的生活问题上拥有道德制高点的权威之间？
They can't touch us! Go in!
他们不能碰我们！进去！
Then a passage opens. The administrator stepped to the side, and the kids rush in.
接着通道打开了。行政人员侧身让开，孩子们冲了进去。
They can not touch you guys.
他们不能碰你们的，孩子们。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Be orderly, be kind. Be kind and respectful. Be kind and respectful. Be kind and show respect. I love you guys.
守秩序，要友善。要友善且尊重他人。要友善且尊重他人。要友善并表现出尊重。我爱你们。
The kids are inside. Soon after I saw the masks video, I saw another from Texas. A mom at a school board meeting opposing critical race theory and masks was disrupting the meeting. An officer goes over to ask her to leave, and then he starts going back and forth with her over her seated teenage son. He was just looking at his lap the whole time. Again, what's it like to be in the middle like that?
孩子们进去了。在看了口罩视频后不久，我又看到了另一个来自德克萨斯州的视频。一位母亲在学校董事会会议上反对批判性种族理论和口罩规定，扰乱了会议。一名警察走过去要求她离开，然后开始就她坐着的十几岁的儿子与她争执。那孩子全程只是盯着自己的腿。再次强调，处于那样的中间是什么感觉？
I've since seen so many school board meetings where kids sit in the audience as parents yell about school closures or Don't Say Gay laws or admissions policies. When school districts started banning books from their libraries, I kept wondering, do students care about that? Doesn't that make the books much more appealing? Or is there a kid out there who's like, I read that book. Why that one? It's not even that interesting.
此后我看到了太多的学校董事会会议，孩子们坐在观众席上，听着家长们大喊大叫，反对学校停课、“不说同性恋”法案或招生政策。当学区开始禁止图书馆里的书籍时，我一直在想，学生们在乎吗？这难道不会让这些书更吸引人吗？还是说有孩子会觉得，“我读过那本书。为什么选这一本？它甚至都没那么有趣。”
This dynamic, adults arguing about the kids right in front of them, it's like a play that's quietly touring the country right, now being reenacted in different places, in different forms, a play in which you never hear from the main characters, people like the kids at the school in the masks video.
这种动态——大人们在孩子们面前争论——就像一出正在全国悄悄巡演的戏，在不同的地方，以不同的形式上演，一出你永远听不到主角声音的戏，比如口罩视频里学校里的那些孩子们。
I don't know. I was just ready for a fresh start. I was ready to be back in school. I thought that was going to be really good.
我不知道。我只是准备好迎接一个新的开始。我准备好回到学校了。我觉得那会是非常好的。
This is a student I'm going to call John. John, like every kid I talked to involved in this particular day at this particular school, asked that I change his name, and I have. The video became very divisive.
这是一个我暂且称之为约翰的学生。约翰和这一天、这所特定学校里我交谈过的每一个孩子一样，要求我更改他的名字，我也照做了。这段视频变得非常有争议。
John says, what you miss, what you don't get from just hearing from the adults in that video is that the biggest thing happening for him right at that moment, and many students, was not masks. It was that this was the beginning of school. Finally, a normal year after such a long pandemic.
约翰说，你错过的、你从视频里那些大人们的言论中无法理解的是，那一刻对他以及许多学生来说，最重要的事情不是口罩。而是学校终于开学了。经历了漫长的疫情后，终于迎来了一个正常的学年。
I hadn't been around most of the people since my freshman year of high school, so there were a lot of things that changed. I know this sounds weird, but a lot of people's voices got deeper, just things like that. And people can drive now. People have jobs. People didn't have them my freshman year of high school.
我从高一之后就没见过大多数人，所以很多事情都变了。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但很多人的声音变深沉了，诸如此类。人们现在可以开车了。人们有了工作。高一时大家还没有这些。
And people have angry parents now, coming with them to school. And there's an officer outside the front door. John was wearing a mask that day, so he was allowed in the school building. He'd walked in about 10 minutes before the confrontation outside, headed to AP English, sat down. John's class started, and then those kids from outside were allowed into the building.
现在人们有了愤怒的父母，陪着他们来学校。前门外还有一名警察。约翰那天戴着口罩，所以他被允许进入教学楼。他在外面的对峙发生前大约10分钟就进去了，前往AP英语课，坐了下来。约翰的课开始了，然后外面那些孩子被允许进入大楼。
A couple of the ones that were in my class knocked on the door. My teacher wouldn't open the door, and they were recording her, being very hostile and confrontational, saying stuff like, you're destroying my educational rights and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then my teacher basically told them, guys, I'm just following the rules and then closed the door on them.
几个在我班上的孩子敲了敲门。我的老师不肯开门，他们就在录像，表现得非常有敌意和对抗性，说着诸如“你在破坏我的受教育权”之类的废话。然后我的老师基本上对他们说，孩子们，我只是在遵守规则，然后关上了门。
Whoa.
哇。
Yeah.
是啊。
What did you make of that?
你对此怎么看？
I was pretty distraught. And then she turned around and looked at us and was like, guys, I can't do this. This is ridiculous. I was pretty distraught because I had never seen people treat teachers like that before.
我当时非常心烦意乱。然后她转过身看着我们，说，孩子们，我受不了了。这太荒谬了。我感到非常不安，因为我以前从未见过人们那样对待老师。
And it changed the way John saw his teacher. She had such little authority in that moment and so many of the other moments that followed in the coming months. She'd ask kids to wear their mask properly. They wouldn't. She struggled visibly, saying things like, I need to find a job somewhere else. John, though, kept trying to restore the original order of things, the way he remembered school to be, the teacher in charge.
这改变了约翰看待老师的方式。在那一刻以及接下来的几个月里，她几乎失去了权威。她会要求孩子们正确戴口罩。但他们不听。她显得非常挣扎，说着诸如“我得去别的地方找工作”之类的话。然而，约翰一直试图恢复原来的秩序，正如他记忆中学校的样子：老师说了算。
I just made it a point to talk with her, not trying to be a teacher's pet, but trying to make it a point to engage in her class and stuff like that. I tried to treat her like she still had the same authority that she did before everything took place.
我只是特别注意和她交谈，不是想做老师的宠儿，而是想在课堂上积极互动等等。我试着像以前一样对待她，就好像她依然拥有权威一样。
Even though she actually didn't?
即使她实际上已经没有了？
Even though she actually didn't, yeah.
即使她实际上已经没有了，是的。
I was in the video.
我在视频里。
I was not.
我不在。
These are two students I'm going to call Daniel and Maddie, who only wanted to speak with me together, who were high school seniors who didn't want to use their real names, and who tag team every time they speak. Maddie was wearing a mask. She says she wore one because her mom wanted her to, so she was let into the school building. Daniel was not wearing a mask. He and his parents didn't agree with the mask mandate, so he was crowded in with everyone at the front door.
这两位我分别称之为丹尼尔和麦迪的学生，他们只愿意一起接受采访，他们是高三学生，不想用真名，而且每次说话都会互相配合。麦迪当时戴着口罩。她说她戴是因为妈妈希望她戴，所以她被允许进入教学楼。丹尼尔没戴口罩。他和父母不同意口罩强制令，所以他当时和大家挤在正门口。
The superintendent and the principal were getting annoyed.
督导员和校长都变得很恼火。
Yeah. The whole day was just kind of weird.
是啊。整天都感觉很奇怪。
No, it was definitely tense.
不，气氛绝对很紧张。
Well, it was just distracting because like everyone did want to just learn.
嗯，这只是让人分心，因为每个人都只想学习。
I asked Daniel, what happened once they were let into the building? He says they put all the kids without masks in the library, and they were there for hours, just as a sort of holding area, I guess, until they figured out what to do with them.
我问丹尼尔，他们被允许进大楼后发生了什么？他说他们把所有没戴口罩的孩子关在图书馆，他们在那里待了几个小时，我猜就是一个临时拘留区，直到他们决定拿他们怎么办。
There was probably 60 or 70 kids, just crammed in the library. There was teachers telling us that we were bad kids and--
大概有60到70个孩子，挤在图书馆里。老师们告诉我们我们是坏孩子，而且——
Naughty no-maskers is what they called them.
他们称我们为“调皮的不戴口罩者”。
Yeah.
对。
Naughty no-maskers?
“调皮的不戴口罩者”？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
The teachers did?
老师们说的？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Yeah. They talked bad about us. It was childish.
是的。他们说我们的坏话。这太幼稚了。
So all of a sudden, everybody in the building, including the adults are on one team or the other?
所以突然之间，大楼里的每一个人，包括大人们，都分成了两派？
That's how it felt.
感觉就是这样。
It was, like, segregated.
就像被隔离了一样。
It was very divided. It had not ever been like that before, and it affected the rest of the school year.
非常分裂。以前从来没有这样过，它影响了剩下的整个学年。
Everyone I spoke with agreed on this. The school year was ruined by what happened that day. Everything after that was tense. People lost trust in each other. Everyone felt less safe, less comfortable. This thing that had not been front and center for most of them became the main event. The students disagreed on which adults were to blame. Some of them blamed the parents, some blamed the teachers, but they all agreed that the adults were to blame.
我交谈过的每个人都同意这一点。那个学年被那一天发生的事情毁了。之后的一切都很紧张。人们失去了对他人的信任。每个人都感到不太安全，不太舒服。这件事对于他们大多数人来说本来不是核心，却成了主要事件。学生们对于该责怪哪些大人意见不一。有些人怪家长，有些人怪老师，但他们都同意是大人们的错。
So many of the big, contentious political issues right now center around kids. Should teachers be allowed to teach about racism, history, sexuality? Will stricter gun laws keep our kids safe in school? Would more aggressive climate policies keep them safer in the future? Which ones? All these policy debates that we've been having for months, that are so central to American politics right now, affect kids more than anyone else.
现在许多重大、具有争议的政治问题都以孩子为中心。老师应该被允许教授关于种族主义、历史、性吗？更严格的枪支法能让我们的孩子在学校更安全吗？更激进的气候政策能在未来保护他们吗？哪一个？这些我们讨论了几个月的政策辩论，对现在的美国政治至关重要，它们对孩子的影响比对任何人都大。
So today's show, from WBEZ Chicago, we talked to kids, living their kid lives in the middle of these divides. Stay with us.
所以今天的节目，来自WBEZ芝加哥，我们采访了生活在这些分裂之中的孩子们。请留下来。
Act 1, This Is Not a Drill. Even though kids are somewhat, obviously, at the center of this next one, I was initially drawn in by the parents, I suppose because this is a particular parental experience that I spend a fair amount of time trying to imagine and trying not to imagine. Dan Kois was in the middle of his workday and he got a text from his 14-year-old daughter.
第一幕，这不是演习。尽管孩子们显然处于下一个故事的中心，但我最初是被家长们吸引的，大概是因为这是一种我花了相当多时间去想象并尽量不去想象的父母经历。丹·科伊斯在工作时收到了14岁女儿的一条短信。
Harper wrote, "There's like a lockdown right now, but people don't know if it's a drill. Everyone's so confused."
哈珀写道：“现在好像封锁了，但大家不知道是不是演习。每个人都很困惑。”
Dan was half a mile from the school. He ran to his bike and immediately pedaled in the direction of his kid's high school.
丹离学校只有半英里。他跑向自行车，立即朝孩子的高中骑去。
So a couple of corners away, a friend of ours, who also has a kid at the high school, was coming out of her front door. And she was like, what's going on? And I said, I got a text too. No time to talk. I'm going the same place as you. And you could see in all the streets that lead up to the school, individual parents making their way toward the school and cars pulling up and taking all the street parking places.
在几个街角之外，我们的一个朋友，她的孩子也在那所高中，正好从前门出来。她问，发生了什么？我说，我也收到短信了。没时间细说。我和你去同一个地方。你可以看到通往学校的每条街道上，都有家长独自向学校赶去，汽车停在路边，占满了所有车位。
Oh my god.
天哪。
So we were all converging and there--
所以我们都在汇合，那里——
So it's like, one by one, every parent is running out of their house toward the school.
所以就像是一个接一个，每个家长都跑出家门冲向学校。
Right. Because every parent has gotten a text from their kid saying, something weird is going on, and we're in lockdown.
没错。因为每个家长都收到了孩子的短信，说发生了奇怪的事，我们被封锁了。
This was last February, in suburban Virginia, but this kind of thing happens all over. Just a few weeks ago, in San Antonio, Texas.
这是去年二月，在弗吉尼亚州的郊区，但这种事到处都在发生。就在几周前，在德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥。
I didn't start losing-- excuse my language-- I didn't start losing my shit until I got to the school and I actually saw officers running all over the place.
直到我到达学校，看到警察到处奔跑，我才——请原谅我的措辞——我才开始崩溃。
For Audrey Cardenas, she didn't get a text from her kid. It was a post on Nextdoor, a neighborhood site-- "Shooting at Jefferson High School."
对于奥黛丽·卡德纳斯来说，她没收到孩子的短信。这是Nextdoor（一个社区网站）上的一篇帖子——“杰斐逊高中发生枪击案。”
There's other parents crying, so I'm like, do you all know anything? And they're like, they're not telling us nothing. They're not telling us anything. I get a text message from my son's best friend. My son's friends call me Mom. And he was like, Mom, I'm stuck in a closet. There's an active shooter. I don't know where Carlitos is at. I honestly thought of going in through the exit room. I went to Jefferson High School so I know how to get in and out because that door-- I mean, I don't know if they fixed it. I graduated 20 years ago.
其他家长都在哭，所以我问，你们知道什么吗？他们说，他们什么都没告诉我们。他们什么都没说。我收到了我儿子最好的朋友发来的短信。我儿子的朋友叫我妈妈。他说，妈妈，我被困在衣柜里了。有持枪歹徒。我不知道卡利托斯在哪里。我真的想过从出口房间进去。我曾就读于杰斐逊高中，所以我知道怎么进出，因为那扇门——我是说，我不知道他们修好了没。我20年前毕业的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
But I'm just like, I'm pretty sure that door is still not fixed. I'm pretty sure I could get in through there.
但我只是觉得，我很确定那扇门还没修好。我确信我能从那里进去。
Had you imagined what you would do in this situation before it happened?
在这件事发生之前，你想象过你会怎么做吗？
I would always talk to my kids about it. And it's not funny, but I always took a picture of my kids in the morning of what they're wearing, just in case something like this were happening.
我总是跟孩子们谈论这个。这并不好笑，但我总是会在早上给孩子们拍张照，看看他们穿什么，以防发生类似的事情。
What? Really?
什么？真的吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Wow.
哇。
Yes. And it annoys the shit out of all three of them, but I'm just like, I need to know. So I identify, OK, well, this is what he was wearing. OK, this person's wearing that. This is your son. This is his body. He was shot multiple times, in my mind.
是的。虽然他们三个都觉得烦，但我就是觉得，我需要知道。这样我能确定，好吧，这是他穿的衣服。好吧，那个人穿成那样。这是你的儿子。这是他的身体。在他脑海中，他被多次射击了。
Jeez. That's something you're thinking about every morning?
天哪。这是你每天早上都在想的事情？
I mean, an 18-year-old kid went into an elementary school and shot 19 students, and all 19 died. Every morning.
我是说，一个18岁的孩子走进小学射杀了19名学生，19人全部遇难。每天早上都在想。
After Uvalde and after every school shooting that happened before Uvalde and the 40 school shootings that have happened so far just this year, a political debate emerged and re-emerges. We have too many guns. We have too few permits, too much mental illness. The teachers should have guns. The issue is really assault weapons. No, it's background checks. It's the Second Amendment.
在尤瓦尔迪惨案之后，在尤瓦尔迪之前发生的每一起校园枪击案之后，以及今年到目前为止发生的40起校园枪击案之后，一场政治辩论出现并再次出现。我们的枪太多了。执照太少了，精神疾病太多了。老师应该配枪。问题真的是突击武器。不，是背景调查。是宪法第二修正案。
And meanwhile, kids keep going to school, and guns keep coming to school, and parents keep standing around outside, grimly trying to imagine what is going on in those buildings during lockdowns. That's what Dan did, standing outside his kid's school.
与此同时，孩子们继续上学，枪支继续进入学校，家长们继续站在外面，阴郁地试图想象封锁期间那些楼里正在发生什么。这就是丹所做的，站在孩子学校外面。
I was definitely trying to imagine myself into that space. I didn't ask either of them if they were scared because that seemed like a dumb question, but I wanted to know what they were thinking about and how they were spending their time.
我绝对是在试图把自己想象成在那个空间里。我没有问他们任何一个是否害怕，因为那似乎是个愚蠢的问题，但我很想知道他们在想什么，他们是怎么打发时间的。
I wanted to know that too. What's it like for the kids who are actually at the center of this thing we seem to have decided is a permanent part of our lives now?
我也想知道。对于那些实际上处于我们似乎已经决定将其作为生活一部分的事情中心的孩子们来说，这是什么样的体验？
I was split between like denial and pants-shitting fear, and I was not in the realm of pants shitting yet.
我在否认和吓得屁滚尿流之间摇摆，而且我还没到屁滚尿流的境界。
Dan's oldest kid, Lyra, missed the loudspeaker announcement about a school lockdown, so she was very breezy about what she assumed was a drill until her sister Harper texted her, no, this is not a drill. Are you OK? The teacher shut off the lights in Lyra's English classroom, locked the door. Everyone crouched on the far wall under some shelves.
丹的大孩子莱拉错过了扩音器关于学校封锁的公告，所以她对这只是演习的假设感到非常轻松，直到她的妹妹哈珀发短信告诉她：不，这不是演习。你还好吗？老师关掉了莱拉英语教室的灯，锁上了门。每个人都蹲在远处的墙边，躲在架子下面。
And that's sort of when the little pangs of fear start to hit because I had both of these stories going, one of which could be the case, but I hope isn't and one of which I need to believe was the case because otherwise, my brain would explode, you know?
在那一刻，那种恐惧的小刺就开始袭来，因为我脑子里有两种情节，其中一种可能是真的，但我希望不是，另一种是我必须相信是真的，否则我的大脑就会爆炸，你知道吗？
Lyra's little sister, Harper, was one floor down in health class, ninth grade. Harper's classmates were clustering along the far wall, but Harper sat in her desk, twisted her body around toward the classroom door, and started filming the door. The camera just watches the closed classroom door. Sometimes her hand shifts or shakes down to her shoes, black Converse, past the health and wellness textbooks, and then back to the door, just waiting.
莱拉的妹妹哈珀在楼下的健康课教室，九年级。哈珀的同学们挤在远处的墙边，但哈珀坐在课桌前，身体扭向教室门口，开始拍摄那扇门。镜头只是盯着关闭的教室门。有时她的手会移动，或者颤抖着看向她的鞋子，黑色匡威鞋，掠过健康课课本，然后又回到门上，只是等待着。
Maybe. I'm filming just in case.
也许吧。我拍下来以防万一。
Whoa, it's almost like you're staging it for there to be a shooter to come in right there.
哇，这几乎就像你在为歹徒进来做现场直播。
Mmm. I thought if it was an actual school shooting, I see all these things of students filming shakily, so I thought maybe if it was happening, I should probably do that.
嗯。我想如果真的是校园枪击案，我看到过所有那些学生颤抖着拍摄的视频，所以我想如果真的发生了，我大概应该拍下来。
A rumor started going around about a kid with a gun somewhere in the school. Harper and Lyra kept waiting for a long time. No shooter, no announcement, no information.
关于学校某个地方有个带枪孩子的传言传开了。哈珀和莱拉一直等待着，等了很久。没有枪手，没有公告，没有任何信息。
So after a great enough period of time had passed, the tension leaked out of the room, and I just went to my desk. You know, it's hard to play Tetris on your phone, so mainly I just wanted to play Tetris on my computer. I didn't think I could get work done. I felt too nervous.
所以在经历了相当长的一段时间后，房间里的紧张感消退了，我回到我的座位。你知道，在手机上玩俄罗斯方块很难，所以我主要是想在电脑上玩。我觉得我没法工作。我太紧张了。
I mean, people were really just talking. Some people weren't even really talking about the lockdown. They were just talking about regular high school drama, that Addison broke up with Owen or something. Wait. Who was it? It was-- I don't know. Some girl was like, oh, no. I'm going to die a virgin. [LAUGHS] And then people heard, and they started laughing. And then her friend was like, no. We're not going to die. It's OK.
我是说，大家其实只是在聊天。有些人甚至没怎么谈论封锁。他们只是在谈论普通的高中戏剧，艾迪森和欧文分手了什么的。等等。是谁来着？是——我不知道。有个女生说，哦，不。我要带着处女之身死去了。[笑声] 然后大家听到了，开始笑。接着她的朋友说，不。我们不会死的。没关系的。[笑声]
And I remember-- I don't know if this is important, but there was a couple, and it was a junior boy and a sophomore girl. And the whole time they were just in the corner being all cuddly and stuff. And [LAUGHS] they were cuddling up to each other. The girl was like, oh, I'm so scared. What do I do? And then the guy was like, it's OK. It's OK. [LAUGHS].
我还记得——我不知道这重不重要——有一对情侣，是个高二男生和高一女生。全程他们都缩在角落里，搂搂抱抱的。而且[笑声] 他们紧紧拥在一起。那个女孩说，哦，我好怕。我该怎么办？然后那个男生说，没关系。没关系。[笑声]
What did you think of that?
你怎么看？
I thought it was funny. [LAUGHS] You guys are weird.
我觉得很好笑。[笑声] 你们真是怪胎。
Lyra texted her Wordle result. She got the Wordle in three.
莱拉发来了她的Wordle结果。她三次猜对了。
Dan, their dad, was still outside with all the other parents, waiting.
他们的父亲丹仍然和所有其他家长在外面等着。
And then Harper texted that she got the Wordle in four, and I told them I also got the Wordle in three. I shared with the parents outside the school that my kids got the Wordle in three or four. And they said, good work, and I shared that with my kids.
然后哈珀发短信说她四次猜对了Wordle，我告诉她们我三次就猜对了。我跟学校外面的家长们分享说我的孩子三次或四次猜对了Wordle。他们说，干得好，我就把这个分享给了我的孩子们。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Then Lyra sent us some tweets from kids who were inside the school, "Someone cancel school or else Imma piss all over the cafeteria floors." Then I sent them some photos of what the outside of the school looked like so they could get a sense of how many police cars were there. And Lyra wrote-- and my bike was in the photo, and she made fun of me for biking to the school.
然后莱拉发给我们一些学校里孩子的推文，“有人取消学校课程，不然我要在食堂地板上撒尿。”然后我发给他们一些学校外面的照片，好让他们知道那里有多少警车。莱拉写道——照片里有我的自行车，她取笑我骑车去学校。
Dan says the weirdest part of this portion of the day was running the two stories in his head, same as Lyra. One story, this is nothing. We're just waiting. The kids will be out soon. And the other story, we're going to look back on this moment when we thought it was nothing, the one right before all the tragedy. But the longer this went on, the first story, this is nothing, had a stronger pull.
丹说，这一天中最奇怪的部分是脑子里同时运行着两个故事，和莱拉一样。一个故事是：这没什么。我们只是在等。孩子们很快就会出来。另一个故事是：我们要回头看这一刻，当我们以为这没什么的时候，就在所有悲剧发生之前的那一刻。但时间拖得越久，第一个故事——这没什么——的吸引力就越强。
So the parents are now-- some of them have gone home. Some of them are still there and texting their kids. There's one guy who's illegally parked in front of a driveway, with his windows open, just doing the longest, loudest work call on his phone, on speakerphone. So we're just all listening to his work call about brokerage fees or something.
所以家长们现在——有些人已经回家了。有些人还在那里给孩子发短信。有个家伙非法停在车道前，车窗开着，正在手机上打着最长、最大声的工作电话，开着免提。所以我们都在听他关于经纪费之类的工作电话。
Wait. He's doing the work call to be close to the school?
等等。他打工作电话是为了靠近学校？
He wanted to be close to the school, so he just sat there, waiting for something to happen, but also doing this work call on speakerphone.
他想靠近学校，所以他就坐在那儿，等着发生什么，但也同时开免提打着工作电话。
I cannot think of a more perfect illustration of what it is like to pretend things are normal in America right now, a more 2022 image than a work-from-home finance guy taking a Zoom call from his car, outside what may or may not be a school shooting in his kid's high school. The incredible peaks of disassociation, the alienation required to proceed with our daily routines while still allowing for the possibility of story number two, of tragedy at any moment. And then something happened.
我想不出比这更完美的例子来说明现在在美国假装一切正常是什么样子了，比一个居家办公的金融男在车里打Zoom会议电话，而车外可能是或者可能不是他孩子高中的枪击案，这更像2022年的写照。难以置信的脱离感，为了继续日常生活，同时允许故事二发生的可能性——即随时可能发生的悲剧——所需要的异化。然后，事情发生了。
Over the loudspeaker, it was a man who no one knew, wasn't our principal, it wasn't his voice. It was just a random guy. And it said, today's Thursday, February 10, 2022. And that's it. It was a deep man voice being serious. And then everyone was like, what? Why would they announce that? And then my teacher said, well, that can't be good.
扩音器里传出一个没人认识的男人的声音，不是我们的校长，不是他的声音。只是一个随机的家伙。他说，今天是2022年2月10日，星期四。就这些。那是一个严肃的深沉男声。然后大家都在想，什么？为什么要宣布这个？然后我的老师说，嗯，这可不是什么好兆头。
Upstairs, Lyra heard the announcement too. And for her, this is when she snapped into story number two. She could feel the other kids in the room do the same thing, tensing up, getting ready for something, to do something.
楼上，莱拉也听到了公告。对她来说，这就是她切入故事二的时候。她能感觉到房间里的其他孩子也是如此，紧张起来，准备着什么，准备去做点什么。
Because I feel like every kid at some point, every high schooler thinks about, well, what would I do if I was in a mass shooting? And I feel like it's everyone's instinct to be like, oh, I'd be brave. I would be kind. I would know what to say to keep people calm. I would know how to escape. I would fight off the shooter, but I just sort of resigned myself, like, if a shooter comes, I'd probably run away or die.
因为我觉得每个孩子在某个时刻，每个高中生都会想，如果我遇到大规模枪击案我会怎么办？我觉得本能会让每个人都觉得，哦，我会很勇敢。我会很友善。我会知道该说什么来让大家保持冷静。我会知道怎么逃跑。我会和枪手搏斗，但我只是有些认命了，如果枪手来了，我大概会逃跑或死掉。
Had you had that thought before?
你以前有过这种想法吗？
Oh, yeah. I think all high schoolers think about it, especially Americans.
哦，有。我觉得所有高中生都想过，尤其是美国人。
Do you think that's true, all high schoolers have had that thought, who am I going to be in a school shooting, if there's a school shooting?
你认为这是真的吗，所有高中生都想过这个问题：如果发生校园枪击案，我会成为什么样的人？
Yes. I would definitely say every single American high schooler has thought about that.
是的。我绝对会说，每一个美国高中生都想过。
Really? I do not have contact with every single American high schooler, nor does Lyra, but once she said this, I was curious, and I started asking around. And every kid I talked to, kids in Texas, New Mexico, Missouri, Minnesota, Michigan.
真的吗？我无法接触到每一个美国高中生，莱拉也一样，但她这么一说，我就好奇了，就开始四处询问。我交谈过的每个孩子，德克萨斯州、新墨西哥州、密苏里州、明尼苏达州、密歇根州的孩子。
Yeah, I've put some thought into it.
是的，我确实思考过这个问题。
Nick is in East Lansing. He's a senior this year, which means he's had more than a decade to watch videos from school shootings, including videos from last year in Oxford, Michigan, which is just a little over an hour away from him and where he heard a student ran at the shooter. Nick says he's imagined being that guy in his school shooting, or he'd help other kids escape.
尼克在东兰辛。他今年高三，这意味着他有十多年的时间观看校园枪击案的视频，包括去年发生在密歇根州牛津的事件，离他只有一小时多一点的车程，他听说那里有个学生冲向了枪手。尼克说他想象过成为那个在自己学校枪击案中这样做的人，或者他会帮助其他孩子逃脱。
And I know a lot of my friends also know-- we know the different ways to get in and out of the building. This past year, I had ceramics, which was on the outside, so that had a door.
我知道我的很多朋友也知道——我们知道进出大楼的不同路线。去年我有陶瓷课，是在外面，所以有扇门。
Nick was the first of many kids I talked to with an alarming command of the various means of egress in their school buildings. It was that way with Michael too, outside Detroit.
尼克是我交谈过的众多孩子中第一个对校园建筑各种出口有惊人掌控力的。迈克尔也是如此，底特律外面。
We have this weird little corridor. And next to the band room is an exit door, but you cannot enter through it.
我们有一个奇怪的小走廊。乐队室旁边有一扇出口门，但你不能从那里进入。
Michael told me, above the exit door is a dropdown ceiling with a missing tile. You could get up there. He heard a couple of years ago the seniors stuck a Christmas tree up there, so he's pretty sure there's space. You could stack the cubbies, get up to the ceiling--
迈克尔告诉我，出口门上方有一个吊顶，缺了一块瓷砖。你可以钻上去。他几年前听说高年级学生把一棵圣诞树塞进去了，所以他很确定那里有空间。你可以把储物柜堆起来，到达天花板——
Push one of the tiles off and then get on top of the dropdown ceiling and escape that way if you needed to.
推开其中一块瓷砖，然后爬到吊顶上面，如果需要的话从那里逃走。
And you had thought about this?
你考虑过这一点？
I thought about it as a possibility. I kind of left it in the back of my mind. And I'm like, all right. If we have to, this is what we do.
我把它当成一种可能性。我把它留在了脑海深处。我想，好的。如果必须的话，我们就这么做。
And then last winter, a student threatened to kill his classmates during sixth period. Nobody knew if he really meant it, so Michael's school went into lockdown, and he ended up in the drumline room, exactly where he'd planned to be. Their band teacher told them to close the door and stay in there. So Michael and about 10 other kids sat on the floor. It was completely dark, soundproof. Everyone was whispering. Michael had thought about this moment so much and now, here it was.
然后去年冬天，有个学生在第六节课威胁要杀死同学。没人知道他是认真的吗，所以迈克尔的学校进入了封锁，他最终待在了打击乐室，正是他计划待的地方。他们的乐队老师让他们关上门待在里面。所以迈克尔和大约10个其他孩子坐在地板上。完全黑暗，隔音。每个人都在低语。迈克尔无数次想过这一刻，现在，它真的来了。
I told everybody the plan within the first five minutes. It was like, if we need to, there's a dropdown ceiling. There's a tile open in the escape-- I call it the escape room now because that's what I think of it as-- but the storage room. One of the tiles is broken. You can jump through there.
我在前五分钟内就告诉了大家计划。就像，如果我们需要，那里有个吊顶。逃生室——我现在叫它逃生室，因为我就是这么想的——存储室。瓷砖坏了一块。你可以从那里跳上去。
What was the reaction? What did people say?
反应是什么？大家说了什么？
The first thing that somebody said was, that's a dumb idea.
第一个人说的是，那是个愚蠢的主意。
That is not how Michael imagined this moment going. Michael, turns out, was not the only one with a plan. He was in a room full of kids who had all prepared for this moment, a room full of band kids who knew each other very well.
这和迈克尔想象的时刻不太一样。原来，迈克尔并不是唯一一个有计划的人。他待在满屋子都为这一刻做好了准备的孩子中间，满屋子乐队的孩子都非常了解彼此。
Michael says everyone was exactly themselves. Alex made jokes. Connor reminded everyone to be calm and reasonable. Lucy agreed with Connor and said, we should hear every side. And the naysayer, who I will not name, who thought everyone's idea was dumb but offered none of his own ideas, nobody was surprised. They kept going. It was constant. We should make a wall of cubbies. No, no, no. We should hide inside the drums. This went on for--
迈克尔说每个人都展现了真实的自己。亚历克斯开玩笑。康纳提醒大家要冷静和理性。露西同意康纳的说法并说，我们应该听取每一方的意见。那个反对者，我就不点名了，他觉得所有人的主意都很蠢但自己又提不出主意，没人感到惊讶。他们一直在讨论。没完没了。我们应该用储物柜筑墙。不，不，不。我们应该躲进鼓里。这持续了——
Around an hour and 15 minutes.
大约一个小时15分钟。
Wow. An hour and 15 minutes? How much is there to say?
哇。一个小时15分钟？有什么可说的？
Depending on what point of view you had, we went through everybody's.
根据你持有观点，我们过了一遍每个人的想法。
Each person got a chance to talk?
每个人都有机会发言？
Yeah. It was, you have five minutes to talk, and then you'll have two minutes to respond. Jump to the next person.
是的。就像，你有五分钟发言，然后你有两分钟回应。跳到下一个人。
Somebody was actually running time?
有人在计时？
Yeah.
是的。
Who was running the clock?
谁在计时？
Conner.
康纳。
Of course. When things got a little tense in this impromptu, Lord of the Flies school shootings planning committee, Alex started playing Pumped Up Kicks at the lowest volume possible.
当然。当这个即兴的《蝇王》式校园枪击案计划委员会气氛变得紧张时，亚历克斯开始以尽可能小的音量播放《Pumped Up Kicks》。
I'm like, dude, stop it. It gets really, really dark. "All the other kids with the pumped up kicks better run, better run faster than my gun."
我说，老兄，停下。气氛变得非常非常阴郁。“所有那些穿着昂贵运动鞋的孩子，最好跑快点，跑得比我的枪还快。”
[MUSIC - "PUMPED UP KICKS" BY FOSTER THE PEOPLE]
[音乐 - Foster the People的《Pumped Up Kicks》]
(SINGING) All the other kids with the pumped up kicks, you better run, better run, outrun my gun.
(歌词) 所有那些穿着昂贵运动鞋的孩子，你们最好跑，最好跑，跑得比我的枪还快。
Dude decided to play Pumped Up Kicks. He is the clown of the class. He's known for being the class clown. The fact that he did that just kind of shook me.
那家伙决定播放《Pumped Up Kicks》。他是班上的小丑。他以班级开心果著称。他居然那么做，让我有点震惊。
Did you find it funny?
你觉得好笑吗？
I found it hilarious, but I'm like, but dude, this is kind of serious right now.
我觉得非常搞笑，但我心里想，但老兄，现在这情况挺严肃的。
Michael told me Alex had played Pumped Up Kicks at other lockdowns too. It's kind of his lockdown thing, but usually he waits till the end. He says that's how you know it's over. You hear that song playing as the police escort you out the building.
迈克尔告诉我亚历克斯在其他封锁时也放过《Pumped Up Kicks》。这算是他的封锁必备，但通常他会等到最后。他说那就是你知道一切结束的时候。你听到那首歌响起，警察护送你们走出大楼。
(SINGING) All the other kids with the pumped up kicks, you better run, better run faster than my bullet.
(歌词) 所有那些穿着昂贵运动鞋的孩子，你们最好跑，最好跑，跑得比我的子弹还快。
Most kids will not experience actual school shootings, but every year, millions of kids will experience something like this-- school lockdowns that are not a drill, that are a sudden, urgent response to a real or perceived threat, lockdowns that can go on for hours, where teachers lock the doors, police are swarming, and helicopters bring in blood, just in case.
大多数孩子不会经历真正的校园枪击案，但每年，数以百万计的孩子会经历类似的事情——并非演习的学校封锁，这是对真实或感知到的威胁突然、紧急的反应，封锁可以持续数小时，老师锁上门，警察蜂拥而至，直升机运来血液，以防万一。
Kids react. Some kids cry. Some kids make out. A fourth grader named Jude told me he filled his backpack with books and held it to his chest. So many of the things I heard about kids doing were somehow generic and deeply individual. A 12-year-old in Birmingham wrote a will that said, quote, "Mom, I want to give my friend Javon everything I own. And that includes the Xbox and games and controllers."
孩子们反应各异。有的哭泣。有的亲吻。一个叫裘德的四年级学生告诉我，他把书塞满书包，紧紧抱在胸前。我听到的关于孩子们的做法，有很多既是通用的，又极其个人化。伯明翰一个12岁的孩子写了一份遗嘱，引用如下：“妈妈，我想把我的所有东西都给我的朋友贾文。包括Xbox、游戏和手柄。”
I heard about a kid in upstate New York who called his parents from the bathroom during a lockdown and came out to them. He didn't want them to learn he was gay later in the news if he died.
我听说纽约州北部有个孩子在封锁期间从洗手间给父母打电话，并在电话里出柜了。他不想如果自己死了，父母后来从新闻里得知他是同性恋。
But the unifying foundation across all these experiences was the feeling of flip flopping between two different stories. Maybe it's nothing, but maybe it's not. And how quickly the certainty that you are in the "probably nothing" story can crumble with one noise, with a text. For Harper and Lyra in Virginia, it was that announcement an hour into their lockdown, the deep man voice on the loudspeaker saying, today is February 10, 2022.
但所有这些经历统一的基础是，在两个不同的故事之间反复横跳的感觉。也许什么都没发生，但也许不是。这种“可能什么都没发生”的故事的确定性，会随着一声噪音、一条短信而迅速瓦解。对于弗吉尼亚州的哈珀和莱拉来说，就是封锁一小时后的那个公告，扩音器里深沉的男声说，今天是2022年2月10日。
And I remember we all just went crazy over that, like, what does that mean? What the hell was that? Who the hell was that? Did anyone recognize that voice? No, I didn't recognize that voice.
我还记得我们对此都快疯了，比如，那是什么意思？那到底是什么鬼？谁在那儿？有人认出那个声音了吗？不，我没认出那个声音。
So I thought that it was like, are they announcing that because that's the day we're going to die? Because I thought when they said the date, it was going to be like, today's Thursday, February 10, and one student has died. I thought they were going to finish it like that, make a whole big thing, but they just said the date. So I was like, what?
所以我以为那是，他们宣布日期是因为那是我们要死的日子吗？因为我以为当他们说日期时，会像，今天是2月10日星期四，一名学生死亡。我以为他们会那样结尾，把事情搞得很大，但他们只是说了日期。所以我心想，什么？
You thought they were going to announce deaths on the loudspeaker?
你以为他们会在扩音器里宣布死亡人数？
I thought they were going to announce like some something has actually happened because at that point, nothing had happened. So maybe oh, they would announce something. We had a school shooter. We had a bomb. We fixed it. Now you can go. We blah, blah, blah.
我以为他们会宣布像发生了什么实际的事情，因为在那之前，什么都没发生。所以也许哦，他们会宣布点什么。我们有校园枪手。我们有炸弹。我们解决了。现在你们可以走了。我们巴拉巴拉。
You're like, what's the rest of that sentence?
你是说，那句话的后面是什么？
Yeah. What's the rest? What happened today?
是的。后面是什么？今天发生了什么？
Which story are we in, and how does this story end? Harper and Lyra stayed in lockdown for around three hours. The normal end of school, 3:00 PM, came and went. Lyra's rehearsal for Annie never started.
我们身处哪个故事？这个故事怎么结束？哈珀和莱拉被封锁了大约三个小时。正常的放学时间，下午3点，来来去去。莱拉的《安妮》排练从来没开始。
Eventually, police came into the classroom with guns, helmets, and tactical gear, told everyone to put their hands up, and they walked in a line out of the building. Later, parents suspected that the loudspeaker announcement was actually the police. A caller had said he was in the school bathroom with two hostages and a gun. The police thought the shooter was out of state, and parents heard that that announcement was a test to see if he was in the building. Would police hear the PA system announcement if they got the shooter on the phone?
最终，警察带着枪支、头盔和战术装备进入教室，让大家举起手来，然后排成一列走出大楼。后来，家长们怀疑那个扩音器公告实际上是警察。有个打电话的人说他被困在学校厕所里，带着两个人质和一把枪。警察以为枪手不在州内，家长们听说那个公告是一个测试，看看他是否在大楼里。如果他们通过电话控制了枪手，警察能听到广播系统公告吗？
They didn't. There were no hostages. There was no shooter, not for Lyra and Harper's school, not for the lockdown in San Antonio, where Audrey, the mom, had her son's picture ready to show to the police. There was just the much more commonplace experience of a school lockdown that had a supposedly happy ending.
他们没听到。没有人质。没有枪手，莱拉和哈珀的学校没有，圣安东尼奥的封锁也没有，在那儿，奥黛丽妈妈已经准备好了儿子的照片给警察看。只是学校封锁这一更普遍的经历，带着所谓的圆满结局。
There are the established, respected rituals of an American high school experience-- prom, graduation, homecoming-- all those times where people come together and share some sort of collective experience. A school lockdown is like that, another kind of school ritual. Like prom, it comes with its own traditions and expectations.
美国高中经历中有着既定、受人尊敬的仪式——舞会、毕业典礼、返校节——所有那些人们聚在一起分享某种集体体验的时刻。学校封锁也是如此，是另一种学校仪式。像舞会一样，它自带传统和期望。
You've imagined what it will be like ahead of time, who you might be. And later, you will look back and say, remember when that thing happened? You'll look back and say, of course that person did that.
你已经提前想象了那会是什么样子，你可能会成为谁。稍后，你会回过头来说，记得那件事发生的时候吗？你会回过头来说，当然那个人会那样做。
A high schooler named Jada in New Jersey told me that years ago, back in first grade, they all hid in the closet for a lockdown and one kid fell asleep. People laughed about that for years. Another time, her freshman year, she wound up hiding in the closet again. That was her longest lockdown, and a student kept asking to go to the bathroom. The teacher kept saying no.
新泽西州一个叫贾达的高中生告诉我，多年前，回到一年级时，他们都在封锁期间躲在衣柜里，有个孩子睡着了。大家对此笑了多年。另一次，在她高一时，她又躲进了衣柜。那是她最长的一次封锁，有个学生一直要求去厕所。老师一直拒绝。
I remember him peeing in a water bottle.
我记得他在水瓶里撒尿。
Actually?
真的？
The teacher was-- yes, he was peeing in the water bottle.
老师是——是的，他在水瓶里撒尿。
Wow. In front of all of you?
哇。在你们所有人面前？
She made him go behind a bookshelf, and we had to move to the front of the closet so we wouldn't see him.
她让他躲到书架后面，我们不得不移动到衣柜前面，以免看到他。
So embarrassing for that kid.
对那个孩子来说太尴尬了。
I think it was embarrassing for all of us because we were just like, oh, this is awkward. He's just there, peeing, and we could kind of hear him. It was just not a good moment.
我觉得这对我们所有人来说都很尴尬，因为我们只是觉得，哦，太别扭了。他就待在那儿，撒着尿，我们还能听到声音。这真不是什么好时刻。
It was a not-good moment that later, after the lockdown, not a single person mentioned again. He never became the kid who peed in the lockdown. Jada says with that one, everyone just had a "what happens in the lockdown stays in the lockdown" attitude about the whole thing. She just thinks they all knew it could have been them.
那是一个不好的时刻，后来，封锁结束后，没有一个人再提过。他从未成为“那个在封锁时撒尿的孩子”。贾达说，那一次，大家对待这件事的态度都是“封锁时发生的事就留在封锁里”。她只是觉得他们都知道那可能发生在自己身上。
Coming up, a middle schooler and a new law grow up side by side. What happens when they finally meet? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个初中生和一部新法律并肩成长。当他们最终相遇时会发生什么？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, kids are at the center of so many political debates these days, like the debate that follows every school shooting about guns and hovers above the lives of actual kids, circling, but never touching down, never really making much of an impact. In our next story, another adult debate that is super heated right now lands directly in the life of one kid our producer, Alix Spiegel, has been spending time with, a kid named Finn in Alabama.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。今天的节目，孩子们如今处于这么多政治辩论的中心，比如每次校园枪击案后关于枪支的辩论，在现实孩子的生活上空盘旋，盘旋着，却从未落地，从未真正产生多大影响。在我们的下一个故事中，另一场现在非常激烈的成人辩论，直接落到了我们制作人Alix Spiegel一直在接触的一个孩子的生活中，一个阿拉巴马州名叫芬恩的孩子。
Alabama recently passed two laws that focus on the lives of trans kids. It's one of many states to do so. There's been a massive increase in these kinds of bills across the country. Republican state legislators have proposed 69 new bills to restrict gender affirming treatment, 14 new bathroom bills, 50 school restrictions, so-called Don't Say Gay bills, and 130 sports bans.
阿拉巴马州最近通过了两项针对跨性别孩子生活的法律。它是众多这样做州之一。全国范围内，这类法案大幅增加。共和党州议员提出了69项限制性别肯定治疗的新法案，14项新的厕所法案，50项学校限制——所谓的“不说同性恋”法案，以及130项体育禁令。
Meanwhile, Finn has been growing up. And what's so special about this next story is that you can see how these bills develop alongside his life as he goes from eighth grade to high school and what happens when they enter the picture. Act Two, Finn Raises His Hand. Here's Alix.
与此同时，芬恩一直在长大。下一个故事之所以特别，是因为你可以看到这些法案如何随着他的生活发展，从八年级到高中，以及当它们进入视野时会发生什么。第二幕，芬恩举起手。这里是Alix。
A year before the laws found their way into Finn's life, he was in eighth grade. And like most eighth graders, he wasn't carefully tracking bills in the Alabama state legislature. His attention was on other things. There were funny YouTube videos to watch and unfortunate amounts of math homework to do and the problem of which color to dye his hair, green or purple or blue.
在法律进入芬恩生活的前一年，他在上八年级。和大多数八年级学生一样，他并没有仔细跟踪阿拉巴马州议会的法案。他的注意力在别处。有有趣的YouTube视频要看，有不幸数量的数学作业要做，还有头发染什么颜色的问题：绿色、紫色还是蓝色。
Finn's one of those kids who likes to learn without liking school, so he's taught himself all kinds of things-- to draw and paint, to play guitar. He even fished his father's abandoned electric piano out of the corner of the music room and somehow taught himself to play.
芬恩是那种喜欢学习但不喜欢学校的孩子，所以他自学了各种东西——画画、弹吉他。他甚至从音乐室角落里把父亲丢弃的电钢琴捞出来，不知怎么地自学了演奏。
Wait, wait, OK. OK. [PLAYING MUSIC]
等等，等等，好吧。好吧。[弹奏音乐]
Finn lives in Grove Hill, Alabama, a small town roughly two hours southwest of Montgomery. In his small house, there are many heartbeats. There's his mother, Jody, and his father, Josh, his two sisters, Allison and Layla, and a Noah's Ark of animals.
芬恩住在阿拉巴马州的格罗夫希尔，一个小镇，大概在蒙哥马利西南方两小时路程。在他狭小的房子里，有很多心跳声。有他的母亲乔迪，父亲乔什，两个姐妹艾莉森和莱拉，还有一艘诺亚方舟般的动物。
So we have Simon, Kevin-- they're brothers-- and Reggie, that's three cats. We have Lobo, which is our dog, the bunny. Allison has two lizards, Speed and--
我们有西蒙、凯文——他们是兄弟——还有雷吉，那是三只猫。我们有洛博，那是我们的狗，还有兔子。艾莉森有两只蜥蜴，斯皮德和——
There's a duck in the backyard that gives off intense anger vibes and a whole bunch of chickens Finn decided to raise because Finn loves animals.
后院有一只鸭子，散发出强烈的愤怒情绪，还有一大群芬恩决定养的鸡，因为芬恩爱动物。
This is just the chicken coop. That's the duck coop.
这只是鸡舍。那是鸭舍。
Oh my gosh. And then you have a one-eyed cat?
天哪。而且你还有一只独眼猫？
Yep. That's Reggie.
是的。那是雷吉。
Hi, Reggie.
你好，雷吉。
When Finn was little, he says he liked Grove Hill a lot. It felt green and free, but as he got older, things got more complicated. Grove Hill is a conservative Christian community, a church-three-times-a-week kind of place, as his mom likes to say. So Finn felt extremely anxious when he first decided to come out as trans in eighth grade. This was in the spring of 2021, after he and his classmates returned from COVID to in-person learning.
芬恩小的时候，他说他很喜欢格罗夫希尔。感觉既绿色又自由，但随着年龄增长，事情变得复杂了。格罗夫希尔是一个保守的基督教社区，像他妈妈说的那样，是一个每周去三次教堂的地方。所以芬恩在八年级第一次决定出柜为跨性别者时，感到极度焦虑。那是2021年春天，在他和同学们从新冠疫情回到线下学习之后。
I didn't want to have to tell it, and I know people can't read minds, but I didn't want to explain it. I just wanted them to be like, yeah. Cool. That's who you are. This is your name. Go with it. Because it was still very awkward back then.
我不想非得说出来，我知道人们不会读心术，但我不想解释。我只是希望他们能说，好的。酷。这就是你。这是你的名字。继续吧。因为那时候还是很尴尬。
Awkward for a million reasons, because the people in eighth grade had known him as a girl for as long as they had known him, because it's always hard to tell people that you see every day something that you're not sure they want to hear. And then, of course, Finn was 14. And pretty much every conversation you have when you're 14 is awkward, but Finn, this naturally shy kid, whose main social goal is to stay under the radar, forced himself. On the very first day of in-person learning, he says he lingered by his teacher's desk after class.
尴尬的原因有成千上万个，因为八年级的人们认识他作为女孩的时间和他认识他们一样长，因为告诉每天见面的人一些你不确定他们想听的事情总是很难。然后，当然，芬恩14岁了。几乎你14岁时进行的每一场谈话都很尴尬，但芬恩，这个天生害羞的孩子，主要的社交目标就是保持低调，却强迫了自己。在线下学习的第一天，他说下课后他在老师的桌子旁徘徊。
I hung back, and I was just like, hey-- I think I said, my name's Finn now, and I use he/him pronouns. And she was just like, oh. It didn't seem like she was disgusted or didn't seem like she wanted to do that. She just seemed more shocked. I don't think she's ever encountered anyone.
我待在后面，我只是说，嘿——我想我说的是，我现在叫芬恩，我用he/him代词。她只是说，哦。看起来她并不反感，或者看起来她不想这样做。她似乎更震惊。我不认为她遇到过任何人。
At this point-- again, this is the spring of Finn's eighth grade year-- trans kids were not yet constantly in the headlines, and Finn says most of his teachers were open and sweet with him.
此时此刻——再次强调，这是芬恩八年级的春天——跨性别孩子还没成为头条新闻的常客，芬恩说他大多数老师对他都很开放和亲切。
Very accepting and understanding.
非常接受和理解。
And so were your teachers good about using the right pronouns and everything?
所以你的老师在使用正确代词等方面做得很好？
For the most part. I mean, it takes anyone a couple minutes.
大部分情况下。我是说，任何人都要花几分钟。
Pronouns are not a small thing for Finn. When people refer to him with the wrong pronoun, he says it's so distressing, he often feels physically ill. It's a response that's not uncommon.
代词对芬恩来说不是小事。当人们用错误的代词称呼他时，他说这让他感到非常痛苦，经常感到身体不适。这种反应并不罕见。
Sometimes it's like a pain in my gut. Sometimes I actually feel like I'm going to puke. Sometimes I just have to walk away and actually make sure I don't.
有时就像胃痛。有时我真的感觉要吐了。有时我不得不走开，确保我真的没吐出来。
But queasiness wasn't much of a problem in middle school. Finn remembers telling his friends for the first time that he wanted to go by "he."
但恶心在初中不是什么大问题。芬恩记得第一次告诉朋友他想被称呼为“他”。
I think they threatened if anyone messed up, they'd punch them. I don't specifically remember that, but I think that was one of the reactions. It made me laugh.
我想他们威胁说，如果有人搞砸了，他们就揍谁。我不记得具体的，但我认为那是反应之一。这让我笑了。
And that's the way it went for the rest of the year. The teachers were open. The kids were on board. And in May, Finn graduated from middle school feeling good, comfortable. Finn's parents, Josh and Jody, were incredibly relieved. They've lived in Grove Hill for most of their lives, and so have a nuanced view of the community, all the contradictions that Grove Hill, Alabama contains.
这一年剩下的时间就是这样。老师们很开放。孩子们也很赞同。五月，芬恩初中毕业，感觉良好，舒适。芬恩的父母，乔什和乔迪，感到无比欣慰。他们在格罗夫希尔住了大半辈子，所以对这个社区有着细腻的看法，格罗夫希尔、阿拉巴马州所包含的所有矛盾。
Jody told me that though many of their friends seemed completely indifferent to whether Finn was trans or not and loved him no matter what, maybe even more people in the community find the experience of her child difficult to understand, and even his existence unsettling-- which brings me to high school. This is Finn's mom, Jody.
乔迪告诉我，虽然他们的许多朋友似乎完全不在乎芬恩是否是跨性别者，无论如何都爱他，也许社区里还有更多的人觉得她孩子的经历很难理解，甚至他的存在让人不安——这让我想到高中。这是芬恩的妈妈，乔迪。
Two days before school actually started, he said, what am I supposed to do if I have to go to the bathroom at school? And I guess I was naive because it still didn't click. I was like, well, what do you mean? If you have to go to the bathroom, go to the bathroom, which is so stupid now. And he said, no. Which one am I supposed to use? I don't want to go to the girl's room.
学校开学前两天，他说，如果我在学校必须去洗手间，我该怎么办？我猜我太天真了，因为我还没反应过来。我说，你什么意思？如果你必须去洗手间，就去洗手间啊，现在想来太蠢了。他说，不。我应该用哪一个？我不想去女厕所。
Now, there were no laws dictating where Finn could go to the bathroom, not yet anyway. So when Jody talked with the school principal about what Finn should do, the principal quickly came up with a solution. Finn could use the single-stall bathroom in the teacher's lounge. This suited him fine. And Finn says at the beginning of school, he was feeling relatively optimistic.
现在，还没有法律规定芬恩能去哪里上厕所，至少暂时还没有。所以当乔迪与校长讨论芬恩应该怎么做时，校长很快想出了一个解决方案。芬恩可以使用教师休息室里的单间洗手间。这对他来说很合适。芬恩说在开学初，他感到相对乐观。
I wasn't as worried with my names or pronouns more than I was finding my locker and finding the classes.
我担心名字或代词的时间并没有超过我担心找储物柜和找教室的时间。
But almost immediately, Finn encountered pushback. It started in geometry class.
但几乎立刻，芬恩就遇到了反弹。这是从几何课开始的。
Teacher was calling roll, and I tried going up to them while they're doing it so they won't call out my dead name, but she told me to sit down. And she called out my name. And when she walked up to me, I corrected her. I tell her that that's not my name, and I use a different name and pronouns. And she was like, no. I'm not going to do that. I'm going to go off of what's on the paper.
老师正在点名，我试着在她点名时走过去，这样她就不会叫出我的死称（Dead name），但她让我坐下。她叫了我的名字。当她走到我面前时，我纠正了她。我告诉她那不是我的名字，我用不同的名字和代词。她说，不。我不会那样做。我只看纸上写的是什么。
And what did you say?
你说了什么？
Nothing.
什么也没说。
And it wasn't just the geometry teacher. There was pushback from Finn's English teacher, his science teacher, even his history and hobbies teacher.
不仅仅是几何老师。芬恩的英语老师、科学老师，甚至历史和爱好老师都表现出抵触。
She pulled me aside and she told me that she respects kids, and she loves kids, and all that. That's why she became a teacher and whatever. She'll do the name, but she won't do the pronouns because that's not what I believe in. I'm not going to do that. I'll just not call on you.
她把我拉到一边，告诉我她尊重孩子，她爱孩子，诸如此类。这就是她成为老师的原因等等。名字她会照办，但代词她不会用，因为那不是我的信仰。我不会那样做的。我只是不点你名就是了。
It's impossible to know the exact why behind this resistance. I reached out to Finn's teachers, the school principal, the superintendent's office. All either declined to talk to me or didn't respond, but it's clear that the national conversation was changing and growing.
这种抵触背后的确切原因是不可能知道的。我联系了芬恩的老师、校长、学区负责人的办公室。要么拒绝接受采访，要么没回应，但很明显，全国范围的对话正在改变和增长。
There were more and more bills directed at trans kids, regulating how they played sports, where they went to the bathroom, what kind of medical care they could get access to, sometimes forbidding any discussion of trans issues in school at all. Did that influence this response? Was it simply teacher luck of the draw? All Finn knew was that very, very unfortunately, the feelings of the teachers seemed to be spreading.
针对跨性别孩子的法案越来越多，规定他们如何参与运动、在哪里上厕所、能获得什么样的医疗护理，有时完全禁止在学校讨论跨性别问题。这影响了这种反应吗？这仅仅是老师们的运气吗？芬恩所知道的只是，非常非常不幸的是，老师们的情绪似乎在蔓延。
Talking to me, saying the wrong pronouns. It affected how other people saw me, but slowly, in a way.
跟我说话，用错误的代词。这影响了其他人怎么看我，但很缓慢，以一种方式。
What do you mean, slowly, in a way?
什么叫“很缓慢，以一种方式”？
It was more gradually obvious that people thought I was a girl.
逐渐明显的是，人们认为我是个女孩。
It was around December of his freshman year that Finn began to think more seriously about medical transition, finding a doctor who could provide hormone blockers and, eventually, testosterone. Finn thought it might help people to see him the right way.
大约在他高一的12月，芬恩开始更认真地考虑医疗过渡，寻找能提供激素阻断剂以及最终提供睾酮的医生。芬恩认为这可能有助于人们以正确的方式看待他。
I'm very-- I'm so insecure about how high my voice can go. So if I was able to access that stuff, it'd probably help a lot.
我非常——我对自己声音能变得多高感到非常自卑。所以如果我能接触到那些东西，那可能会有很大帮助。
When Finn talked to Jody about getting treatment, hormone blockers and testosterone, she told him she was open to the idea, but needed to make sure it was safe first. She said she'd research it. So Finn plowed forward, played in band, suffered through geometry, and also became increasingly distressed, worried that his teachers would continue to misgender him, that the kids at school would continue to question whether he was truly a boy, that it would all just keep on getting worse. And then one day in geometry, Finn hit a breaking point.
当芬恩和乔迪谈论接受治疗——激素阻断剂和睾酮时，她告诉他她对这个想法持开放态度，但首先需要确保安全。她说她会研究一下。所以芬恩继续前进，参加乐队，在几何课里受苦，也变得越来越苦恼，担心老师会继续用错误的性别称呼他，担心学校里的孩子会继续质疑他是否真的是个男孩，担心这一切只会变得更糟。然后有一天在几何课上，芬恩达到了崩溃点。
She either dead named me or misgendered me, one or the other, in front of the class. And then she passed out a test paper. And all my papers, I usually write, Finn, he/him, just like a little reminder note. And I did that. After writing that, I wrote, it was either, please stop dead naming me or misgendering me or I will kill myself.
她要么叫了我的死称，要么用错了性别，两者必居其一，当着全班同学的面。然后她发下了试卷。我所有的试卷，我通常都会写上：芬恩，he/him，就像一个小小的提醒便条。我照做了。写完之后，我写道，不是“请停止叫我的死称或用错性别”，就是“不然我就自杀”。
I remember writing it and then erasing it and then writing it back. I was scared of what was going to happen, saying that. Like, if they would tell my mom. I was scared my mom would believe it, so I erased it. But then I was like, I don't care. This teacher needs to stop. So I wrote it back, I did my test, and I turned it in.
我记得写了它，然后擦掉，又写了回去。我很害怕说出这些话会发生什么。比如，如果他们告诉了我妈妈。我害怕我妈妈会相信，所以我擦掉了。但后来我想，我不在乎。这个老师必须停止。所以我写了回去，我做了测试，交了上去。
Finn says he wasn't really going to commit suicide if the teacher didn't use the right pronouns. He just couldn't think of another way to communicate his distress. The problem of suicide is incredibly serious among trans kids. A recent study showed that in 2020, roughly one in two trans youth seriously consider suicide, though when parents and schools are accepting, the rate of actual suicide attempts falls dramatically.
芬恩说，如果老师没有使用正确的代词，他并不是真的要自杀。他只是想不出别的方法来表达他的痛苦。自杀问题在跨性别孩子中极其严重。最近的一项研究表明，2020年，大约每两个跨性别青年中就有一个认真考虑过自杀，尽管当父母和学校表现出接纳时，实际自杀企图的比例会大幅下降。
Finn's mom, Jody, did talk to the teacher about this note. And she says that she walked away from the conversation feeling at least a little bit better. She told me she could see the teacher cared for Finn, but felt like using his right name and pronouns was against her religion.
芬恩的妈妈乔迪确实和老师谈过这张便条。她说她离开谈话时感觉至少好了一点点。她告诉我，她能看出老师关心芬恩，但觉得使用他正确的名字和代词违背了她的宗教。
She wasn't at all abrasive with me. She didn't tense when I brought anything up. She actually-- she cried when I started explaining some things like, OK well, this is what you did, but this is how it's made him feel. And she was just like, oh my goodness. I'm so sorry. I never-- that wasn't my intention.
她对我一点都不粗暴。当我提起任何事时她都没有紧张。她实际上——当我开始解释一些事情时，她哭了，比如，好吧，这是你做的，但这是这让他感到的方式。她只是说，天哪。我很抱歉。我从没——那不是我的本意。
So that was Finn before the bills passed-- fragile, struggling to settle into high school and get through his day. And then the lawmakers in Montgomery stepped into Finn's life.
所以这就是芬恩在法案通过之前的情况——脆弱，努力适应高中生活并度过每一天。然后蒙哥马利的立法者走进了芬恩的生活。
Well, listen. We want to make sure that we protect these kids. There's a lot of reasons, a lot of things we do in the state to make sure that they can't have alcohol, can't have tobacco, they can't have vaping.
好吧，听着。我们想确保我们保护这些孩子。我们在这个州做了很多理由，很多事情，以确保他们不能接触酒精，不能接触烟草，不能吸电子烟。
This is Alabama State Representative Wes Allen, one of the Republicans who sponsored the bills, talking to reporters in the press room of the state capitol on April 7 of this year, immediately after the bills passed. The first bill, HB 322, was a bathroom bill. And for Finn, would mean he'd have to use the girls restroom, not his single stall in the teacher's lounge.
这是阿拉巴马州众议员韦斯·艾伦，赞助这些法案的共和党人之一，今年4月7日在州议会大厦新闻发布室对记者发表讲话，就在法案通过后立即。第一项法案，HB 322，是一项厕所法案。对于芬恩来说，意味着他必须使用女厕所，而不是他在教师休息室的单间。
The second bill, SB 184, made it a felony to provide any minor in the state with gender-affirming medical care, meaning Finn wouldn't have access to the hormones that could help him with his voice.
第二项法案，SB 184，将为州内任何未成年人提供性别肯定医疗护理定为重罪，这意味着芬恩将无法获得能帮助他改善声音的荷尔蒙。
That's not protecting these minors.
那不是保护这些未成年人。
As Representative Allen explains, he and his colleagues believe that teenagers are too young for this kind of treatment.
正如艾伦众议员所解释的那样，他和同事们认为青少年太小，无法接受这种治疗。
Their minds are not fully developed to make these decisions on these medications and surgeries, and that's what the bill is about, to protect minors.
他们的大脑没有完全发育成熟来对这些药物和手术做出这些决定，这就是法案的内容，保护未成年人。
To be clear, the American Medical Association, the American Association of Pediatrics, the American College of Physicians, a whole bunch of groups all say kids should have access to gender-affirming medical care and oppose legislation like this.
需要明确的是，美国医学协会、美国儿科学会、美国内科医师学会，一大堆组织都表示孩子应该有权获得性别肯定医疗护理，并反对这样的立法。
I went to visit Finn and Jody in May, shortly after the bills passed, but before Jody had a chance to sit down and tell Finn about them. She told me she held off when she first heard, because the fate of the medical bill was immediately thrown into question by a court challenge, and she didn't want to disturb Finn unless it turned out to be absolutely necessary.
我在五月份去拜访芬恩和乔迪，就在法案通过后不久，但在乔迪有机会坐下来告诉芬恩之前。她说，当她第一次听说时，她推迟了，因为医疗法案的命运立即受到法院挑战的质疑，她不想打扰芬恩，除非事实证明绝对必要。
But then, the first night I was there, Finn, Jody, and I were sitting around, talking, and the subject of the legislation came up. And suddenly, we found ourselves inside the conversation that Jody had been delaying, the conversation where she explained to Finn that a bathroom bill had passed and would become official law over the summer break, so when Finn started 10th grade in the fall, he might be forced to use the girls bathroom.
但后来，我在那儿的第一晚，芬恩、乔迪和我坐在一起聊天，立法的话题被提出来了。突然之间，我们发现自己置身于乔迪一直在拖延的谈话中，她向芬恩解释说，厕所法案已经通过，将在暑假期间成为正式法律，所以当芬恩秋天开始上十年级时，他可能会被迫使用女厕所。
The bathroom bill, that's supposed to go into effect on July 1 of this year, which means if nothing happens and there's not anything to come up and stop it, at the start of the school year, that's in effect.
厕所法案，定于今年7月1日生效，这意味着如果什么都没发生，没有东西出来阻止它，在学年开始时，它就生效了。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
As soon as Finn heard about the bathroom bill, his face drained of color, and you could see tears in his eyes.
当芬恩听到厕所法案时，他的脸瞬间变得苍白，你可以看到他眼里的泪水。
It's OK to be upset. We are upset with you.
难过是正常的。我们和你一起难过。
Jody told Finn she knew this was not the news that he wanted to hear, but she felt like he needed to understand now that there could be a different arrangement in the fall. She said she had talked to the school principal, who in the past had been incredibly helpful and kind to Jody and Finn.
乔迪告诉芬恩，她知道这不是他想听到的消息，但她觉得他现在必须明白，秋天可能会有不同的安排。她说她和校长谈过了，校长过去对乔迪和芬恩极其有帮助和亲切。
Even he was like, look, we don't know what's going to happen. We don't know. We're all going to try to hold out hope that things go the way we want them to. And if things don't go the way that you deserve them to go, as a human being, we'll go from there and regroup.
即使他也说，看，我们不知道会发生什么。我们不知道。我们所有人都会努力抱有希望，希望事情按照我们想要的方向发展。如果事情没有按照你作为一个人类应得的方向发展，我们会从那里开始，重新整顿。
Jody started talking through some of the regrouping options, but Finn just sat silent, saying nothing. Then one of the many animals who live in the house appeared in the doorway. It was Finn's personal cat, Simon.
乔迪开始讨论一些重新整顿的选项，但芬恩只是沉默地坐着，什么也没说。然后，住在这房子里的众多动物之一出现在门口。那是芬恩的私人猫，西蒙。
Look. Simon immediately knows you're upset because he's racing right up here.
看。西蒙立刻知道你很难过，因为它正冲过来。
[CAT MEOWS]
[猫叫声]
What a baby. We'll get it all figured out. All is not lost. I can always bring my Bible up there and whack them with it if I need to. You OK? OK.
真是个宝贝。我们会把这一切都搞清楚的。并没有全盘皆输。如果需要的话，我随时可以带着我的圣经过去敲他们。你还好吗？好吧。
A couple of weeks after this conversation, school let out, and I didn't see or talk to Finn and Jody until August, right before the start of the school year. Jody told me that Finn had had a good summer. He's in his first long-term relationship with a 16-year-old who lives one town over. They spent a lot of time together. They watched YouTube, went roller skating, and of course, spent countless hours playfully insulting each other in that way that teenagers always do.
在那次谈话几周后，学校放假了，我直到8月，学年开始前才见到并和芬恩、乔迪谈话。乔迪告诉我芬恩过了一个愉快的暑假。他和住在隔壁镇的一个16岁孩子建立了第一段长期关系。他们花了很多时间在一起。他们看YouTube，去溜冰，当然，花了无数时间像青少年总做的那样戏谑地辱骂对方。
Also, over the summer, the bathroom bill that so distressed Finn quietly became law. Jody told me that a couple of days before my visit, she'd reached out to the school principal to see if they'd keep Finn's accommodation and was eventually told that Finn would have access to the bathroom, but only Finn, and only as long as no other kid in school came out or complained in any way. For whatever reason, Finn had been grandfathered in, but the door was closed behind him.
此外，暑假期间，让芬恩如此痛苦的厕所法案悄然成为法律。乔迪告诉我，在我访问前几天，她联系了校长看看他们是否会保留芬恩的住宿安排，最终被告知芬恩将可以使用洗手间，但只有芬恩，而且只要学校里没有其他孩子出柜或以任何方式投诉。无论什么原因，芬恩被祖父条款豁免了，但身后的门关上了。
Jody said Finn was deeply discouraged by the arrangement, and that after he'd found out, he'd taken a nosedive in terms of mood. He was sure the bathroom would be taken away and that people would be even worse about using the right pronouns. Jody said he started talking almost relentlessly about dropping out. It wasn't just the law, she said, but after the difficulty of the previous year, this extra piece of weight felt to him like it, quote, "sealed his fate."
乔迪说芬恩被这个安排深深打击了，在他发现之后，他的情绪陷入了低谷。他确信洗手间会被拿走，人们会更糟糕地使用错误的代词。乔迪说他开始几乎不间断地谈论辍学。她说，不仅仅是法律，但在经历了过去一年的困难之后，这额外的分量让他觉得，引用一下，“注定了他的命运。”
It's true that the Finn I found when I returned to Grove Hill felt like a different kid. He seemed much smaller than before, emotionally, even physically. And you could tell from the way that he was talking that he was in that kind of pain that bubbles out into the open, even when you don't want it to.
确实，当我回到格罗夫希尔时发现的芬恩感觉像个不同的孩子。他看起来比以前小得多，在情感上，甚至身体上。从他说话的方式中，你可以看出他正处于那种即便你不想，也会冒出来的痛苦之中。
For example, towards the start of our conversation, I asked what I thought would be a fun warm-up question. I'd been privately wondering, how would I begin this story? What was the right way to introduce this kid to people like you? So I asked Finn to decide for himself.
例如，在谈话开始时，我问了一个我以为会很有趣的热身问题。我私下里一直在想，我该如何开始这个故事？向你们这样的人介绍这个孩子的正确方式是什么？所以我让芬恩自己决定。
OK. If you could choose, how would the story of you start?
好吧。如果你可以选择，你的故事会怎么开始？
I don't know. Just a kid trying to be happy.
我不知道。只是一个努力想要快乐的孩子。
Why do you look like you're about to cry? Because you're about to cry?
为什么你看上去快要哭了？因为你快要哭了？
You saying that makes me want to.
你这么说让我想要哭了。
Is it about going back to school?
是因为要回学校了吗？
(TEARFULLY) I mean, I don't want to. I don't like school.
(含泪地) 我是说，我不想去。我不喜欢学校。
We talked about the bathroom work-around, how precarious it was.
我们谈到了洗手间的变通方案，它是多么不稳定。
I was glad that they still kept the bathroom for me, but I also think it's stupid that if anyone else wants to feel comfortable at school in a bathroom, since they can't.
我很高兴他们仍然为我保留了洗手间，但我同时也觉得这很愚蠢，如果其他人想在学校里感到舒适，因为他们不能。
Finn's solution if the bathroom got taken away is what a lot of people do in this situation.
芬恩如果洗手间被拿走的解决方案，是很多人在这种情况下所做的。
If the bathroom's taken away from me, I'll just-- just not use the bathroom.
如果洗手间被拿走了，我就——干脆不用洗手间。
At school all day?
整天在学校？
Yeah. Just avoid drinks, I guess, breakfast. Because I really don't use the bathroom that much, anyways, at school.
对。避免喝水，我想，早餐也是。反正我在学校其实不怎么用洗手间。
In the weeks before this story was scheduled to air, I called around to some of the lawyers and caregivers in Alabama who monitor trans kids to find out what they were seeing. And the reports I got back were pretty grim.
在这个故事原定播出的前几周，我联系了阿拉巴马州监督跨性别孩子的一些律师和护理人员，看看他们看到了什么。我得到的报告相当严峻。
One lawyer told me that she was getting reports that even the kids who always loved school were suddenly resistant to going, and there were serious concerns that there would be increased incidence of self harm. In a way, despite how difficult this has been for him, Finn is kind of a best-case scenario. He has parents who unconditionally support him.
一位律师告诉我，她得到的报告显示，即使是那些一直喜欢学校的孩子也突然抗拒上学，人们非常担心自残事件会增加。在某种程度上，尽管这对芬恩来说很困难，芬恩算是个最好的情况。他有无条件支持他的父母。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话响]
Hello.
你好。
Hi, Finn. How are you doing? It's been so long. How are you?
你好，芬恩。你怎么样？好久不见。你怎么样？
Yeah, it's been a minute, yeah.
是啊，有一会儿了，对。
A few days ago, I spoke with Finn for the first time since I visited in August and found out that he was doing surprisingly well.
几天前，我自八月访问以来第一次与芬恩交谈，发现他出奇地好。
How are the teachers treating you so far this year?
老师今年对你怎么样？
The teachers are good. No problem with some.
老师很好。有些完全没问题。
Finn said all his teachers were being respectful about pronouns and name stuff this year, and though there had been a couple of incidents, including a pretty serious fistfight, he was holding on for sure. No one had come forward to complain about the bathroom, and no other kids had come out, so Finn found himself preoccupied with less existential problems.
芬恩说他今年所有的老师在代词和名字问题上都很尊重他，虽然发生过几次事件，包括一场相当严重的拳头仗，但他肯定能坚持住。没有人站出来抱怨洗手间，也没有其他孩子出柜，所以芬恩发现自己被不那么存在的问题所占据。
Grades, trying to get ungrounded, slowly. Hanging out with friends, trying not to miss something.
成绩，努力慢慢地解除禁足。和朋友一起玩，尽量不错过什么。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Speaking of grades, I got all A's.
说到成绩，我得了全A。
You got all A's on your report card?
你的成绩单上全是A？
Yeah.
对。
Congratulations.
恭喜。
Thank you. It was all low A's, though. I think two of them were 92's.
谢谢。不过都是低分A。我想其中两个是92。
Finn told me he doesn't think about the laws every day, but when he does, they make him mad.
芬恩告诉我，他不会每天都想法律，但当他想到时，它们让他生气。
I guess just because I'm a kid, I don't get why people decide to do certain laws that have nothing to do with them. I think it's stupid, in a way.
我猜只是因为我是个孩子，我不明白为什么人们决定制定一些与他们无关的法律。我觉得这在某种程度上很蠢。
Finn and his family are doing what they can to adapt, and they did have a small victory recently because of a different law, one that's been on the books forever. It lets anyone change their name to whatever they want. Finn and Jody got the paperwork done over the summer. And a few weeks ago, a new social security card arrived in the mail.
芬恩和他的家人正在尽其所能适应，他们最近获得了一场小小的胜利，多亏了一部不同的法律，一部一直存在于书本上的法律。它让任何人都可以把名字改为任何他们想要的。芬恩和乔迪在暑假完成了文书工作。几周前，一张新的社会保障卡寄到了信箱。
In the eyes of the law, "Finn" is now Finn's official name. No teacher or legislator can say anything different. Still, the laws passed earlier this year hover in the air as Finn goes about his day. From his perspective, they don't protect him. They just create obstacles. They've made the job of being Finn more difficult.
在法律眼中，“芬恩”现在是芬恩的正式名字。没有任何老师或立法者能说出不同的内容。尽管如此，随着芬恩度过每一天，今年早些时候通过的法律仍然悬在空中。从他的角度来看，它们并没有保护他。它们只是制造了障碍。它们让做芬恩这份工作变得更困难了。
Alix Spiegel is one of the producers of our show.
Alix Spiegel是我们节目的制作人之一。
One more thing before we close this cereal bar down. I saw an article recently, as I was working on this episode, from NBC News. And it weirdly connects the two stories in today's show in a way I did not see coming. It's an investigation into a popular conspiracy theory. Maybe you've heard it. It is that schools all across the country are offering litter boxes to kids who identify as cats.
在我们关闭这个麦片吧之前还有一件事。当我制作这一集时，我最近看到了一篇NBC新闻的文章。它奇怪地连接了今天节目中的两个故事，以一种我没预见到的方式。这是一项对流行阴谋论的调查。也许你听说过。那就是全国各地的学校都在为认同猫的孩子提供猫砂盆。
If you hadn't heard this one, sorry. This is all over social media. The story is kids are telling their schools they're cats, and schools are accommodating them by providing litter boxes.
如果你没听说过这个，抱歉。这在社交媒体上到处都是。故事是孩子们告诉学校他们是猫，学校通过提供猫砂盆来容纳他们。
At least 20 Republican politicians have repeated that this is happening, that this is, quote, "a growing crisis," that schools are just allowing kids to identify as whatever they want. This gender identity stuff has gone too far, and there are kids who are only communicating in, quote, "barks and hisses," and it's gotten so extreme that schoolchildren are now using litter boxes. So that's the rumor.
至少20名共和党政客重复了这件事，说这是“一场日益严重的危机”，学校只是允许孩子们认同他们想要的任何东西。这些性别认同的东西走得太远了，有些孩子只用“叫声和嘶嘶声”来交流，而且已经变得如此极端，学生们现在都在使用猫砂盆。这就是传言。
NBC News looked into this. They investigated each one of these claims and tried to find schools where this is actually happening. They reached out to every school rumored to have a litter box-- over 20 places-- and they found one, a whole school district in Colorado. They had kitty litter, but they were not keeping it because kids were identifying as animals. No kids were identifying as animals.
NBC新闻对此进行了调查。他们调查了每一个这样的指控，试图找到这种事真正发生的学校。他们联系了每一个据传有猫砂盆的学校——超过20个地方——他们发现了一个，科罗拉多州的一个整个学区。他们有猫砂，但他们保留它们不是因为孩子认同为动物。没有孩子认同为动物。
The district, Jefferson County School District, is home to Columbine High School. Schools in the Jefferson district have cat litter in case they have to go into lockdown during a school shooting. The litter is part of their overall plan if there is an active shooter situation. They have litter and buckets so kids have somewhere to pee, somewhere that's not in a bottle, in a closet.
该学区，杰斐逊县学区，是科伦拜恩高中的所在地。杰斐逊学区的学校有猫砂，以防万一他们必须在校园枪击案期间进入封锁状态。如果发生持枪歹徒情况，猫砂是他们整体计划的一部分。他们有猫砂和桶，这样孩子们就有地方撒尿，有地方不是在一个瓶子里，在一个衣柜里。
They've kept cat litter on hand for years, along with candy for diabetic students, a map of the school, flashlights, wet wipes, and first aid items. The litter boxes are about school shootings.
他们多年来一直储备猫砂，还有为糖尿病学生准备的糖果、学校地图、手电筒、湿巾和急救用品。猫砂盆是关于校园枪击案的。
I don't know. I just keep thinking about the hours we've spent talking about kitty litter and the money that went into making this non-issue a series of talking points on top of other non-issues that also became talking points about where kids pee in school, when in America, we don't have a problem of kids saying they're cats and being provided with litter boxes. What we have are adults who have accepted that school shootings will continue to happen, and they're preparing. What we have, which kids will tell you, is an actual problem, actual threats, actual fear, actual trauma, actual deaths.
我不知道。我只是不断思考我们花了数小时谈论猫砂，以及投入资金让这个非问题成为辩论点，在这个问题之上，还有其他也成为辩论点的非问题——关于孩子在学校在哪里撒尿，而实际上在美国，我们并没有孩子说他们是猫并被提供猫砂盆的问题。我们有的是已经接受校园枪击案将继续发生并为此准备的大人们。我们所拥有的是，孩子们会告诉你的，一个实际的问题，实际的威胁，实际的恐惧，实际的创伤，实际的死亡。
Our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman and edited by Laura Starecheski. Valerie Kipnis produced the prologue of the episode. The people who put together today's show include Chris Benderev, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Tobin Lowe, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ryan Rummery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由Nadia Reiman制作，Laura Starecheski编辑。Valerie Kipnis制作了这一集的序言。参与制作今天节目的人包括Chris Benderev, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Tobin Lowe, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ryan Rummery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, senior editor, David Kestenbaum, and our executive editor, Emaneule Berry. Special thanks today to Rachel Lissy, Sidney Duncan, Dylan Nettles, Rose Saxe at the ACLU for helping us count laws, and all the parents who gave us permission to talk to their children.
我们的主编是Sarah Abdurrahman，高级编辑David Kestenbaum，执行编辑Emaneule Berry。今天特别感谢Rachel Lissy, Sidney Duncan, Dylan Nettles, Rose Saxe在ACLU帮助我们统计法律，以及所有允许我们与孩子谈话的父母。
This story about lockdowns was inspired by the Slate podcast Mom and Dad are Fighting, where I first heard Dan Kois share his experience. Original music in Act 2 by Christina Courtin and Michael Lavelle. Editorial support for that story from Tuck Woodstock.
这个关于封锁的故事灵感来自于Slate播客《Mom and Dad are Fighting》，我在那里第一次听到Dan Kois分享他的经历。第二幕的原创音乐由Christina Courtin和Michael Lavelle制作。该故事的编辑支持来自Tuck Woodstock。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. There's videos and lists of favorite shows and tons of other stuff there. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org, This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过750集的档案。那里有视频和最爱节目列表，以及其他大量的东西。再次强调，ThisAmericanLife.org，《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交易所传送到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. He's out this week, but he called just to remind everyone that dressing up for Halloween is optional at our office.
像往常一样感谢我的老板，Ira Glass。他这周不在，但他打电话提醒大家万圣节装扮在我们办公室是可选的。
I'm not going to force anybody. I'm not putting masks on anybody. That's not my job.
我不会强迫任何人。我不会给任何人戴口罩。那不是我的工作。
I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Chana Joffe-Walt。我们下周会带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。